hi there III 2015 brings us the division
Andrew we got to play it what are your
thoughts on that alright so this is the
first time pretty much anybody's got to
play the division yeah and it's not at
all what I expected
I don't know about you but it's
definitely more of an RPG than a shooter
which maybe that's what everybody's
expected that's not what I expected and
so it threw me for a little bit of a
loop that's not to say we didn't have a
fun time because we were on a team
together with chat going against
basically two other teams in this dark
zone mode right where you go into a
respawn restricted area fight some AI
enemies we got there's like one loot
crate right right in a very obvious
place right and it gave you a weapon
that said hey this is contaminated so
you have to extract it from the dark
zone um it reminds me of like an Engram
for example in destiny where you have to
take it to somebody in order to actually
like use it so you couldn't like equip
it right yeah yeah so like we just as a
septa like well we actually did yeah
each team kind of had like its own
Street you cross into the dark zone you
move in and then you all mean the middle
and that's what you fight over
yeah is the loot cream but like
everybody got their own loot right like
we weren't fighting over the same loot
it wasn't like a race to the loot yeah
but once once you get past like the AI
enemies there's a what does it call the
extractions yeah and you you send up a
flare and it starts to countdown and
then as as you can see from that one
demo they showed that's when pvp kind of
kicks in and you can actually like
attack the other teams you can stop the
other people from extracting yeah and we
did that right away so the idea yeah we
were like no we're gonna be broke really
yeah so like that kind of resented an
interesting way of playing but the more
I think about it the more I'm like wait
is this actually gonna be fun
like doing these missions it's like
granted this is the demo they're showing
to the public at e3 so they have to make
it it's a sync so they have to make it
go by quick and like kind of not be
complicated right so these missions will
get stale
real fast because it's like the same
thing over and over and over
I'm sure but he said the guy we he was
helping us out he said this is just a
small they're gonna have huge like
extractions those dark zones that have
like multiple checkpoints spawn points
that you don't say not to like start all
the way over yeah and like way harder
like different extraction actual zones
which when he was like alright bring up
your map right and to find the
extraction zone and it's like everything
from the divisions past showings that
cool map that like grows out of the
floor yeah it's like goes back camera
pulls back you're like oh that was
awesome and I'm like wait but like when
you actually play what am i doing yeah
things that haven't was like you know we
had like a dev behind it's doing these
pointers and there was a woman we're
like you know we both we we got really
close like I can fellow player right
yeah we both kind of maneuvering around
yeah you know my station is like I said
out loud
what's melee how do I kill him and he
was like oh we don't have that oh we
even put that in yet he made it sound
like they were gonna add it in me so
literally I'm just pushing this guy back
and forth and I'm running out of ammo
like yeah it was and if there was a
state where if you get hit enough you
like just go down into a state but you
can crawl on like one hand but you can't
do anything with your other hand you
can't take shots or stab or anything and
you have to wait for a revive that's
simple like we were both down and that
is this we both like moving around the
guy like circling but he didn't know
what's going on and he couldn't quite
like get a grip on the controls to just
like kill us both and he was like
reloading and it was so like it's a
little off cuz like just jumping from
cover it's everything so sticky but it
gets messy and it's not like precise as
I like for a shooter so I mean the more
I think about it the more I'm like wait
what this game but there's plenty modes
probably coming out there's plenty of
stuff still to see but it was I'll say
this was really enjoyable in the moment
probably because
were on a team going against other teams
and yeah aspects is always like you know
super good what I mean yeah no I don't
think so man
I mean you know it's just a little
sliver of the division sure the division
doesn't get divided don't get divided